so so hold on a couple of weeks ago you
got hit by a car yeah i got hit by a car
but it was like it was set up they used
mathematics
and all types of technology you hurt
your ankle to hurt my ankle enough
to you know saying i heard it enough and
then you ended up
in jail for three days four days i was
in a mental hospital and i was feeling
and
feeling like a [ __ ] my crack
hits are
very good from the center that gives me
hits
they gave me the situation but you went
without crack for how many days
basically somebody who looks over
this is what's going on based somebody
who looks over the united states it's
awesome
i got on some in my storyline like if
you're gonna be here
you can't just be lollygagging or
something like that and i guess they saw
it was like
and then they started but they
definitely targeted like bad people and
stuff like that so
i think i like i like the whole
situation like i see you guys walking
around
like y'all supposed to be here so it's a
blessing i
i like the situation at the end like
seeing people walking around just
looking at him like
yeah now it's where it's supposed to be
can i ask you a question
so you went without any crack for how
many days two days
they didn't want to feed me either i
don't know
but i'm murdered oh i claim myself as
murder that's my name
anti whatever you know so
hold on you seem more clear headed than
i've ever seen you okay
daddy and i'm wondering if maybe the the
fact that you didn't have crack for a
few days might have helped you
yeah the whole thing is going to stop
because everything i'm saying right now
but do you see that nature secrets it's
no secret it's once you're in a
situation you got to get
out it's no it's no secrets if i tell
you everything in my storyline you're
going to be like
honey you know i'm saying take a sip of
liquor
hit the blank but it's not going to do
nothing to the world anymore
so i think that's you know i really
think that's true
like you know anything and it's not
going to do nothing i think i'm the last
of
discovery and all this you know i'm
saying chit chatting over the blind
trying to figure out stuff
unorthodoxy and orthodoxy and an
orthodoxy so
i really do believe that i think this is
it you're so cute
i don't see nothing else we got cars
freeways
amanda make that [ __ ] let me ask you a
question
do you do you see that you're a little
more clear-headed right now
yeah like 21 savage you know yeah we
gotta have a skinny bad guy i think
do you like that kim k mama do you like
the way you feel right now
oh man they gotta make antibiotics have
a conversation
do you like do you like the way you're
feeling right now in thinking you're the
way your brains work i don't feel
nothing
i i don't think i think i'm a robot i
don't know
we have to bring this down i was in the
car driving my day yesterday and they're
like
my people too smart we got to bring it
down like just seeing because i'm
putting y'all on i'm just like okay
crack money crack money crack money
sweet
this gives me hope nobody gonna rip me
off i got 20. let me get a duh let me
get a dime
come back and get another dime so i get
the most from my pay and that goes into
y'all
you know i'm seeing ebt and all of that
so
i don't know if any of this is true i
love your personality when you're here
when you're clean i love your
personality because that's what i'm
saying why can't we
are real [ __ ] chinese egyptians
whoever came up with how i
am how i feel and stuff it's it's no
error you know what i'm saying
so
you're so cute i wish you could get
clean and stay clean
who's that blonde hi i got gray i'm an
old lady
yeah i'm just gonna sound so happy to
know excited to know that michael's been
watching me my whole life oh my god
so happy like my day is set my whole
life is set
um i just wanted to say sorry to
everybody on
pomona where is downtown for having to
listen to my thoughts and my makes my
make sense
my little whatever thank you to the lady
that does my voice and
talk to me while i'm faded so thank you
guys i love you and
you guys family i love you guys so much
thank you you guys are always there so
that's it
okay amanda how are you
amanda what's going on
what's going through what's on your mind
today
okay i just wanted to address my voice
or whatever
somebody does my voice so i am a full
robot so i just wanted the world to know
that
i'm not trying to put my actions on
somebody else but
i am a full robot so that's it good to
know amanda let me ask you a question
yeah so how do you spend your day i see
you walking around but you're [ __ ]
crack all day
i know but at the end when i smoke crack
the energy or the crack goes throughout
the neighborhood so people don't like
giving me crack
hey beautiful hey guys i just wanted to
apologize about the thing
downtown or whatever with the animals or
whatever and i forgive
i forgive my mom i forgive my dad
whatever but i wanted to be around me
and i apologize to everybody there's
stuff that people
close to me don't know and hopefully
eventually they'll find out i'm not
the people people are helping me out so
i don't really want to tell them
so eventually you guys will be proud of
me and once you guys hear the word on
everything and the background story on
everything
you guys will know that i'm a leader not
a follower and
i i really do love you guys and i really
do fit
but i think because of my nervous
condition
it all doesn't matter have you ever had
in a situation like
where something's going bad but it's
like overall
you're just like it don't matter so
that's why i'm that's that's all i want
to say that's a good attitude
yeah what happened to your nose amanda
um
i got beat up by two crackheads in a
motel room i got away
i'm orthodox 24 7. so i didn't really
remember what happened but i remember
going into the room
so you've been using the word orthodox
quite a bit lately yeah they put
yeah what's relaxed all the time but in
a good way
and it goes when you say orthodox what's
your definition of orthodox
because they're helping me whole they
orthodox people to
give me dates and stuff it's kind of
embarrassing is it pimp
yeah man i want to be
um my old friend jordan or whatever
she's a real class act so
i really like her and when i'm dead and
gone
just look to hers for how i want to be
and me
so you gotta play nothing yeah i feel
like i'm
tell me what happened when they beat you
up i got away
the paramedics came to the um
to the gas station but i didn't want to
go to the hospital so
amanda i'm worried about you getting i
hate to say it but i worry about you
getting killed out here
yeah the important people know the
background of my story so i feel
comfortable
certain people that are close to me
don't but
it's just so everything can stay
comfortable and everything can stay good
so i feel good about everything you know
i'm saying yeah but it's so crazy
dangerous out here
yeah for you to be walking around with
no shoes like you are right now
yeah you're walking around you're
wearing a tank top and no shoes
how many times have i seen you wearing a
tank top and nothing else pretty much
that's your uniform
i tank top and a wig and no shoes
and i just looked at her when i'm dead
and gone that's it
all right bye gorgeous
i just want to say that i want to start
my video real fast because
i just wanted to show off my new
hairstyle so that's it amanda what are
you going to do with your life
i'm going to go get my card from my my
my glass house so that i can get my own
apartment
and get away my own way
you get your own apartment you can't
even support yourself
rent down here is like 56
56 dollars
but you're gonna keep using crack yeah
you don't want to get off it nobody does
and
do you have any desire to to get clean
and get your life straight and all that
or you just want us you want to stay
down here
i just want to switch highs with
somebody and have fun
you have no desire to get back to your
old life like when you were in school
how long
that was boring everybody was fake to me
and how is everybody to you today i
don't think you have any friends today
yeah i don't have friends everybody's
orthodox just think i'm somebody else
when i talk to him
most of people just want to use you for
i want to use other people i'm kind of a
vulture now
it's hard for me to make money clearly
they
teleport pedophiles and bad people when
they're doing bad things
to come date me for my prostitution so
i try to make them feel comfortable and
that i'm not judgmental
and i'm definitely not a pedophile they
wanted to make me one
you know what i'm saying
because um i keep messing with this guy
michael take off that silly wig and uh
take it off um
machine
i keep messing with him so
i just want kim k to know that i don't
want
um michael anymore
and are you happy
how y'all see me is eye-opening
so amanda i'm constantly nervous
am i happy no i know
that
i'm like kind of like a f plus
prostitute
student whatever and so
i kind of make jokes out of it and
[Music]
make everything seem like the best thing
is going on
but it's not your family and i are
trying to get you
taken somewhere so you can get treatment
maybe get clean and
we're all hoping that maybe when you get
clean you might be able to think more
clearly
about your about your life your future
and stuff like that
yeah because right now right now whether
my mama's alive or dead
i want to be the best looking amanda i
can be so hopefully
i earn my luck today i want new feed i
want
new blood new face everything so
hopefully everything works out being
skinny i don't know how i got skinny
i do i'm pretty sure i'm a clone so
i think i think that drug you're smoking
might have something to do with it
oh god everybody's learning so well yeah
look at some of the other bodies down
here there's a lot of people that have
amazing bodies
it's called the crack diet
you guys put a fast one on me
so michael jordan hurts me
but i'm i'm gonna be okay
and i don't want no girl close to my age
doing my thoughts
and video gaming me
so nah i'm not feeling
but i am thankful did you sleep last
night
no that's two nights in a row you
haven't slept i know i don't sleep at
all get on tv
do you eat
yeah i eat very unhealthy
i wasn't even fat before i was just
weird-shaped so that's even worse than
fat
so i don't know i hope people come
during the day and after i go to sleep
michael sabrina whoever comes right
not just with that crazy clone the
[ __ ] police can't touch me
um i think the police are just
frustrated by you
yeah they know you're out there they
don't care they pick you up a hundred
times
they watch me all day but they don't see
that they're looking at a fake thing
well i don't think anyone knows how to
help you the police your dad
me no one you can help me by
taking me somewhere fine where would you
like to go
i want to go somewhere besides walking
around
where's your okay i want to get how you
guys are about crack
you do but we don't touch it
you want to stop using huh do you want
to stop using
no no i don't know
your story's sad amanda i know
it's it's over today because i'm
relaxing the whole world would like to
help you and
no one knows how yeah i'm tired of black
girls
jumping on me and stuff because it's
stupid
if they know my story
people have been passing by me saying
rude things about my story
like on some awesome so
that's stupid when i get money from you
mark i give it out i give it away
that's ambition well i think it's for
people to get out of my face
when you're dead your dad and i give you
money to avoid
you doing more dangerous things for your
addiction that you're not gonna
you're gonna do whatever it takes to get
your money for crack so if your dad and
i give you a little bit of cash that
i don't murder these people they
they do certain things to get murdered
that are crazy
i'm automatic right now today so
you're gonna call me
i really feel pain i really
feel it
that's how she wants me to look i had a
friend tell me
you still look fat or whatever
i can tell she's putting that on me
you're beautiful
now we have problems because you putting
that on me
you're beautiful i want to teleport in
somebody's body and
look at myself
i set her indoors i don't want to be
hurt
i want to be there's nothing i'd like to
see more than a clean
embarrassing rambling amanda
and i'm thinking from a mechanical
standpoint too when i say kim kardashian
and amber rose
so i want to be there you think about
mike wearing
a body or nothing
i was thinking with their body hmm
could go what the [ __ ]
um i didn't say that
i don't know what she's doing right all
right
i am we need to figure something out for
you i don't know what it's going to be
but
today i was coming it's hard when you
don't want it
i need new feet but that's it thank you
america
you